fois anne claire rafflegeau infirmières
et membre du collectif inter urgence
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors racontez nous un peu
est ce que vous êtes inquiète des
derniers chiffres des contaminations
toujours en haut c'est ce que les
hôpitaux sont aujourd'hui suffisamment
équipé pour éviter l'engorgement des
services d'urgence et de réanimation
qu'on a pu constater en début d'épidémie
notamment et qui ont amené au
confinement de la population
alors effectivement oui on est inquiets
parce que en manque de personnel
clairement il avait beaucoup de demandes
de disponibilité ou alors de démission
suite à la première vague
on manquait déjà avant sa de personnel
et on risque d'en pâtir lors de cette
deuxième vague donc vous croyez à une
deuxième vague
ben on voit bien que en tout cas dans
certaines régions et notamment par ile
de france il ya quand même une
augmentation des dépôts des patients
atteints qui viennent consulter aux
urgences d'hospitalisation alors pas
forcément en réanimation il faut parfois
en médecine mais il ya de plus en plus
de deux patients qui sont hospitalisés
quand même pour moi
pour le président et la problématique
lorsqu'on met des patients koji dans une
unité où il n'y a pas que des patients
dédié farias pas une unité qui est
uniquement dédié aux candidats c'est le
risque de transmission croisée et c'est
ce qui s'est passé lors de la première
vague c'est que l'un services entiers
finalement fini par être contaminé donc
au delà de du manque de matériel qu'on
qui est assez récurrent mais je l'espère
qui sera quand même au rendez vous 6 1
s'il ya vraiment une augmentation des
cas et qu'il ya une réelle deuxième
vague
ce qui m'inquiète le plus c'est le
risque de contamination chez les croit
les soignants ce qui va entraîner des
arrêts maladie est également des burnout
ce qu on a quand même des soignants qui
sont clairement au bout du rouleau
on peut le voir sur les commentaires sur
twitter nous sur les commentaires de
notre site internet ou de nos réseaux
sociaux les gens le disent et on a peur
que justement on n'y soit pas au
rendez-vous et de manquer cruellement de
personnel ah oui en même temps ça vous
est infirmière racontez moi comment ça
se passe au sein de l'hôpital dans
lequel vous exercez qu'est ce que c'est
aujourd'hui le quotidien des personnels
de santé en france alors moi j'ai quitté
l'hôpital suite à cette première vague
parce que je fais partie des gens qui
n'ont pas supporté
maintenant je suis en contact en
permanence avec avec mes collègues je
sais que ça commence à être très
difficile que qui a davantage de
patients qui viennent pour du coup vide
mais pas seulement
il ya également toutes les personnes
qu'on tue des compensées leur pathologie
qui n'avaient par consultés qu'ils
consultent la après l'été il ya le début
de certaines petites épidémies et on
sait pertinemment que à partir d'octobre
novembre on aura beaucoup de grip on
aura beaucoup de gastro et en plus de sa
localité on sait que ça va deux on sait
que pertinemment que en période
hivernale des as déjà les urgences sont
saturés c'est l'une des raisons pour
laquelle nous collectif interrogeant que
nous étions en grève déjà depuis début
2010 neuf là cette saturation
mais en plus de ça on rajoute une
pandémie avec une maladie qui est
extrêmement contaminantes qui a déjà
fait des dégâts chez effectivement la
population mais également chez les
soignants un peu on ne peut qu'être
inquiet effectivement alors vous dites
j'ai quitté mon hôpital ou lors de la
première vague parce que je n'ai pas
supporté qu'est-ce que vous n'avez pas
supporté le management tout court du 2
du gouvernement
enfin la réalité tout ce qui a été mis
un prix
mis en place par le gouvernement
n'étaient pas adaptés pas de masque par
voilà il sait également que ça
extrêmement traumatisantes comme comme
expérience en on est là trois mois à
travailler à enchaîner les journées sans
navigue à vue en plus concertée cas pour
tout le monde hein on connaissait pas la
pathologie on la connaît mieux
maintenant donc effectivement on peut
l'apprendre
on la prend en charge différemment mais
c'est quand même une expérience
traumatisante on manquait de personnel
en permanence on ne se remplacent les
uns les autres puisqu'il ya eu des
contaminations entre nous et forcément
j'ai préféré - quitter l'hôpital louis-h
vous êtes sentis abandonnés par les
pouvoirs publics
oui mais bon c'est pas je pense que ce
n'était pas seulement la conséquence de
la première vague du coded staff et je
le rappelle nous ça fait quand même
depuis avril 2019 qu'on tire la sonnette
d'alarmé et plus le coït je pense que
c'était trop les mensonges répétés des
du gouvernement et les exemples des
protocoles d'hygiène qui change tous les
jours toutes les semaines par à cause
d'une gestion de pénurie c'est pas
tolérable on nous a pas respectées on
nous a mis en danger
on a mis en danger des patients on n'a
quand même jamais autant fermer deux
sacs mortuaires de masi enfin c'est pas
c'est pas ça que je veux faire dans ma
vie j'ai décidé de quitter en tout cas
l'hôpital public pour un temps en temps
qu'il est comme ça le gouvernement a
annoncé plusieurs mesures d' aide pour
les personnels de santé pour les
hôpitaux en france on now
notamment mise en place le ségur c'est
loin d'être suffisant
je pense que effectivement même si il ya
une augmentation salariale qui est qui
est inédite dans dans ce métier là le ça
ne suffit pas les conditions de travail
et les conditions d'accueil des patients
nous ont fait ce travail là par vocation
c'est un travail extrêmement humain on
nous demande de travailler à la chaîne
de faire de l'abattage et de ne pas
prendre en compte l'humain c'est à dire
qu'on nous demande de faire d'eux des
actes et c'est extrêmement frustrant
lorsqu'on travaille dans dans un dans le
dans ce milieu-là de de faire ça et et
je pense que sur la durée on ne peut pas
tolérer de travailler comme ça je le
sais maintenant que que la durée de vie
d'une infirmière dans un service c'est
trois ans quatre ans et plus ça va plus
ça dix minutes et les mesures qui ont
été prises au ségur sont clairement
insuffisantes ayant plus elles sont il
ya beaucoup de communication dedans
c'est que oui certes une augmentation
salariale non remet en cause les 35
heures il ya plein de petites choses
comme ça qui sont pas elles qui sont pas
suffisantes et ne sont pas adaptés à la
situation
anne-claire rafflegeau merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes infirmières et est membre du
collectif inter urgence merci beaucoup